crypto Market is crashing and here's why
earlier this week binance's CEO
announced that they will be selling 500
million dollars worth of ftt tokens ftt
is the token of one of their main
competitors the FTX exchange this
negatively impacted the FDT price and
since the exchange used FDT as
collateral The Exchange had to withhold
withdrawals more information has come to
light like the ftt exchange could be
insolvent and so could their founder and
as a result the US is now investigating
the FTX exchange the binary CEO then
said that they're going to be buying the
FTX exchange to try and help but as more
information comes to light it looks like
that offer is going to be pulled and to
make it all worse according to many
sources the majority of FTX exchanges
legal team have now quit it's not
looking good this is why we say not your
keys not your coins don't leave your
cryptocurrency on an exchange make sure
to always take self-custody by using a
non-custodial Hardware wallet